oh
so
you
right
um
awesome
no no where's awesome all right
uh
all right
actually
yes
okay
foreign
representing businesses in every
community
across
clairvoyant
associated builders and contractors who
represent open shop commercial
contractors
retail association of nevada we have
the large retailers thousands of small
retailers pharmacies
grocery stores and general merchandise
business
i'm a board member with startup nv which
is a statewide business incubator that
supports
nevada's business owners and
entrepreneurs
we've got the supply chain right here
i'm your closure
good morning
uh
please
step
you guys get a fly in our first one
it's true
like a little napkin
sure
it's hard to see what though now
he was very proud of that he was flying
on it
no more no no more
well our former majority leader in the
senate
um the state senate was very proud of
himself at one time he flew on air force
one and
stole one of the ashtrays
that's a bill raggio's story for those
nevadas
you
oh
okay
which
really awesome
hello everybody thank you very much
thank you very much and nice to meet you
all
we have a great group of people and i
understand they'll be endorsing me
and i like great endorsements we have
some
really great endorsements we've had some
great newspaper endorsements over the
last
three days so maybe i could just
introduce nevada trucking association
the retail association of nevada that's
a big deal
associated builders and contractors big
stuff
and the startup nevada that's a very
good one lisa well thank you very much i
really appreciate it
so maybe you could say a few words and
we'll
talk and appreciate it very much hey
thank you mr president
i'm paul inos i'm the ceo of the nevada
trucking association
very blessed to represent an industry
that touches every single sector of our
economy
and that was something that really
became apparent during this pandemic
this administration took unprecedented
steps to ensure
that not only did our truck drivers have
proper ppe so they could be safe
but that we could deliver all of the
things groceries toilet paper
meat to our grocery store shelves
deliver medical testing equipment to our
first responders
tax reform that this president has
implemented has been phenomenal for our
industry
it has allowed us to invest in safer
cleaner trucks
that are out there on the road it has
enabled us to increase the wages of our
truck drivers
and for our drivers new hours of service
rules
that have been passed by this
administration have enhanced safety
have made those rules a lot more
flexible for our truck drivers
and allowed them to get home at night
this administration has protected
our smallest trucking companies those
independent owner operators
giving them the ability to contract to
be able to go out there and start their
own business work for themselves achieve
the american dream
and a very human level mr president this
industry
has trained almost a million truck
drivers across the country
to recognize and report signs of human
trafficking
and we commend your administration's
efforts and successes in combating the
sequel
thank you very much mr i love what you
just said human trafficking that's great
thank you very much
appreciate it please
mr president mary lau i am the president
and chief executive officer of the
retail association of nevada
we represent large retail operations
pharmacies grocery stores and very small
retail
operations also our major retailers in
the form
of brochures pharmacies home improvement
facilities
we're honored to serve as essential
workers in the united states and we
appreciated paul bringing toilet paper
how about anybody else
we needed that product but our small
businesses we represent several thousand
and we are so grateful for the ppp
loans and we humbly request that we get
consideration for
for forgiveness of that loan at 150 000
or less and in liability reform
and we're looking at that both of those
very seriously
it is amazing we um
appreciate the fact that you have built
an amazing economy
and we firmly believe that this
president
is the key for making the economy great
again and as another side mr president i
am a small business owner
in a woman-owned firm and we
very much appreciate your views on
safety
your views on operation and your support
of
our law enforcement we are proud to
serve
and honor to support thank you very much
that's really nice i appreciate it very
much
thank you mr president my name is mack
bybee i'm the president
ceo of the associated builders and
contractors of nevada we want to thank
this president for spearheading his
initiatives on workforce development
um creating an economic environment
where construction was
booming pathway to success
from top to bottom what's happening here
in nevada and throughout the country
i want to thank you for your opportunity
to for second chance
programs helping those that have served
in
prison but now are looking to correct
their lives and have a second shot at
opportunity in this country
you know i don't have as much to say as
the other ones but we know that
your economic environment your tax
package all those things were incredible
for the business community
and for construction and that goes again
from the very top
all the way down to the very bottom of
everybody in the industry we want to
thank you for that
really nice i appreciate it very much
thank you
good morning i'm lisa song sutton i'm a
board member with startup nevada
i'm a local entrepreneur and a former
miss nevada
startup nv's role is a statewide
incubator here in nevada
we support small business owners and the
entrepreneurial ecosystem
and we can't do that without support for
me personally
as an attorney turned entrepreneur i
have four companies that i started here
in the silver state across
varying sectors real estate food and
beverage
retail and shipping e-commerce all of
those industries
were affected not a single sector was
spared here in nevada
and thanks to you and your
administration
for the swift action that you took to
make sure that small business owners
like myself and the entrepreneurs that
we help
have the resources available to them to
make sure that we could keep the lights
on
to pay our staff and to just stay afloat
during a really uncertain time
rebuilding the economy is what's
important and in order to do that we
have to support american businesses and
american entrepreneurship
so now is the time for private sector to
come off the sidelines
to stand up for our communities to stand
up for our small businesses
and recognize that results matter we see
that every day within our small
businesses
that being action driven results
oriented detail oriented
and having hustle and heart are what
will carry us through to not only
survive but also thrive
you mr president have all those
qualities as well it's something that we
recognize
and we're very grateful for all the work
that you do and your support of american
entrepreneurs
thank you lisa very much so nice i
appreciate it
anybody else anybody you're together a
couple of
doubles that's good well you've been
well represented if that's the case
so i want to thank everybody we're
heading to arizona
we have a couple of very big ones in a
little while very big ones we have
they've all been big i think you've seen
it you've been witness to it
i don't think anybody's ever seen
anything like this in the history of our
country politically
uh there's tremendous support poll
numbers are very good you don't see the
real poll numbers we have
poll numbers in wisconsin where we're up
one
and yet i see abc comes out abc
washington post
of course they had us 12 down last time
of course right before the
end i think they were even but they had
us 12 down
about two weeks before and uh we ended
up winning so
you know one of those things but they
came out with one
down 17 and we have one where we're plus
one and most of them have us pretty even
in wisconsin so uh just suppression
polls it's a shame they can get away
with it
uh it's almost uh if you think about it
it's almost like a campaign contribution
to the dnc
the good news is our people understand
it they understand it very well they
went through it four years ago
and it was actually worse four years ago
if you think about it but they went
through it
we're really up in uh almost all of the
states that we're talking about
most of the states we're up even or very
close
doing fantastically in florida doing
fantastically in north carolina
we have a michigan poll that just came
out we're two up in michigan
we have a very good wisconsin poll that
just came out
we're one up rasmussen has us at
53 52 yesterday
53 and head to head nationally
we're up in a rasmussen poll and
rasmussen was one of the most accurate
four years ago so we tend to look at the
ones that were accurate
four years ago uh pennsylvania we think
we're going to do fantastically there
there's tremendous
energy and we've never seen enthusiasm
like this and i think the honest
reporters will say
in the history of doing what you're
doing i don't think anybody's ever seen
enthusiasm like this
our voters are going to vote early but
they're really going to vote
on tuesday they want to wait till
tuesday that's what the tradition has
been
at least the tradition with me happened
last time too
and i'm calling it a great red wave and
i think you're going to see something
that's going to be
uh amazing some will vote a little bit
earlier but they do want to vote they
want to go to the
bowling booth and vote for the most part
the
early ballots were doing much better
than anticipated we
assumed a certain number i think they
are underperforming
and i think on tuesday we're going to
over perform and we'll see what happens
at the end of the day hopefully it won't
go longer than that hopefully
the few states remaining that want to
take a lot of time after november 3rd to
count ballots that won't be allowed by
the various courts because as you know
we're in courts on that we just had
a big victory yesterday in wisconsin on
that
matter so hopefully that won't be
happening okay
we're heading out now to a great state
arizona
it's a terrible thing what uh what i'm
witnessing is terrible
and frankly that the uh the mayor or
whoever it is that's allowing
people to riot and
loot and not stop them is also
just a horrible thing i saw the event
everybody did it was on television it
was a terrible event
i guess that's being looked at very
strongly we have federal
the federal government is looking at it
also but the rioting in philadelphia you
have to stop it they have to stop it
it's uh it's a local thing as you know
we're not
we we don't send unless we're asked if
they ask if they ask for help we'll be
there very quickly
but they should bring in their national
guard if the police need help
and they should do something you can't
let that go on again
a democrat-run state a democrat-run city
philadelphia we don't have that
we don't have it the republicans don't
have it and you'll have more and more of
that and you're gonna have it and you're
gonna have it strongly
you gotta you can't let that happen
we're looking at the shooting yes we're
looking at the shooting and if asked to
go in and help we will do that we have
to be asked as you know by the governor
uh they should be able to handle it
themselves police i know the police very
well in philadelphia i think they gave
me an endorsement
and they're not allowed they were told i
understand to stand back
to stand back don't do anything and
people are breaking into stores and
walking out with washing machines and
walking out with all sorts of
things and it shouldn't be allowed
that's no way to
do it you got to have law and order
you've got to have respect for
our police the police were told to stand
back now maybe
that's not so but that's what i was told
upon very good authority
you can't allow that to happen we're
watching it very closely and we're
waiting for a call
if they want help we're there we'll be
in there within one hour
we're ready to go within one hour yeah
please follow on that um
former vice president has uh condemned
the writing
uh but he's also saying if he's elected
uh president
uh that he will push for a commission uh
to look into
how do you go about diminishing these
types of situations with
mental health situations crises
give you a response to that and yeah i'm
sure
the former vice president has been doing
this for 47 years he's been doing it
badly
this is a group that he supports
he doesn't want to condemn them i saw
that he doesn't want to condemn them
you have to condemn you have to be
strong
you can't have chaos like that
and he'll be very very weak he hasn't
gotten to the best of my knowledge
any endorsements or certainly if he has
it's very few
i've gotten almost every law enforcement
endorsement in the nation texas florida
louisiana oklahoma
ohio almost everyone in the nation
i think we might have even gotten
pennsylvania which is great but they
have to
they have to be able to do something
about it the problem with joe
joe's all talk and no action you got to
have some action you can't let that
happen
i went to school in that city i love the
city of philadelphia
you can't let that happen to
a wonderful place like philadelphia you
can't let it happen well
i'm going to see you in arizona thank
you very much everybody
you